[Music]
I to point out first that I'm very happy
to be here this
[Music]
evening
the truth is in here for 89 annually
join today lwith cr.com mugclub
[Music]
[Applause]
that's what I
know
[Music]
change
I feel great I'm not in pain mhm if you
see me go show it's the neck thing that
came back and then it turns into fake
headaches and where it's up and you're
like how's my eyebrow
sore I'm just in headphones here glad to
be with you uh I know yesterday we had
the Vic uh Vic thing went up there so it
was a little bit different like cake
yeah
right off the bat and everything on my
headphones sounds off here we switched
them to these new headphones so now I
can't hear you guys I mean I can but I
can't VI I got it wrong the very first
it's okay it's the very first phrase no
yesterday with him there I know if you
guys didn't watch I got it wrong today
Viv vi
vi gosh he's got a thing about that too
VI all right you've been waiting on that
one all
day yes so uh we have a lot to get to
today uh later on the show we have an
exclusive uh you guys fund this through
your memberships over there at Mud Club
with undercover so L credit.com mugclub
but we actually have an exclusive at the
Dallas pramas rally let's call it what
it is not pro Palestine Pro Hamas rally
um so Jinder snap will be on here to
talk about it we're going to have a bet
today is Jim Jordan Jim Jordan going to
be this neck thing is giving me like
stroke mouth it is yeah it's weird my
mouth is the equivalent to Katie Holmes
left
eye
shouldn't
laugh L I said you would have complete
Enlightenment it's remarkably similar
so we will be uh talking about Jim
Jordan having a bet how many rounds do
you think he goes and then the Biden
campaign right now is kicked off which
by that I mean off the reals Yakuza did
you just switch something in my
headphones just now no yes you did yes
you did I just had a whole total change
in my
headphones don't change anything I
adjusted to the change that you made
before he went air and didn't check and
now you're changing it while I'm talking
so now I got to adjust it again I can
see him creeping he's like oh I got to I
forgot to change his level and now he
changed it and now I got to I'm going
through sound B we got
have Donald Trump is under a gag order
who
giv yeah good luck we'll be talking
about that too okay we'll be talking
about a lot so I guess my question to
you first is do you support Jim Jordon
this house who would you like to see be
house Speaker I think you know what try
uh an NCAA uh National Champion wrestler
we've never done it it's first place I
just want to try something new yes so
one point they said wine was good for I
started so I started smoking wine dipped
cigars didn't work didn't work it's not
my heart's
horrible Captain Morgan how are you sir
number two I am doing far better than
you when it comes to necks sorry man I'm
doing well I would ask you how you're
outside of the neck how you doing you
know it's kind of all encompassing right
now it's just going like it's like Fred
Flintstone's thumb after he gets to
switch chairs yeah uh and then in third
chair when you hear this you know him
you love them this just just brings a
smile to your
face you can follow him on Instagram at
joshin I know it's easy to confuse fire
Stein right now with everything going on
in the global conflict Mr firin how are
you I'm good man I'm good how are you
doing good let this is this this energy
seems like none of us are ready for a
show I had a good weekend I had a good
weekend I went to the beach did you yeah
I took my dog and my kids to the beach
my wife yeah she came too uh it was a
nice time went to Messy Jesse season
Aberdine oh yeah how did that go yeah it
was fine it was good lot of crowder fans
there man why was it called it yeah
messy Jess it's cu the bartender yeah
well no what I thought the owner the
owner's named Jesse um used to be sloppy
Jesse she got married to this guy Dustin
they're a nice couple don't understand
how that changes they have my debit card
though your Nick I left my debit card
there for real oh wow stuff all over the
yeah and I left my laptop on the
airplane hope he got messy Insurance
yeah yeah messy insurance
let's go to this this was just one of
those things you know here's a question
I have for you remember when we grew up
in high school and I don't know what you
guys we had to call it keyboarding class
we had to learn how to type the and then
we also had to learn how to cross
reference like search hey if you're
looking for something to research for a
paper that would say enter in these
different keywords you can't find
anything now on YouTube you can search
for something you just watched you can
enter in the title and it doesn't show
up Google and YouTube are becoming more
and more like Instagram where it's by
Design you can't can't find anything so
this was something that was at the top
of the trends I watched I laughed my ass
off and then uh I tried to find it and I
couldn't find it so it took us a while
the researchers here today they were
doing some work so this is a a gay or
transgendered Jewish New
Yorker uh covering all your B giving a
speech in support of I know it's like
the irony train oh it's just it doesn't
it doesn't run anymore that guy likes
two different kinds of shmear I don't
it's like he okay prepare it looks like
if Gary Gman and uh Dylan mulany had a
baby
okay Jewish New Yorker supporting
Palestine uh of course in an entirely
mentally unstable way as Jewish New
Yorkers nailed it we are here to say not
in our names with his
hand all right well I understand where
you're coming from and by that I'm I
mean I don't and I know that this is a
little childish and stupid but uh buckle
up
[Applause]
buttercup
our
our in
[Music]
our took a little creative license there
transgender New York Jew who supports
Palestine
that was Hamas being defeated if you
didn't catch yeah just in case you
didn't catch that that was that was Gaza
just to be clear wasn't wasn't Israel no
no no yeah this was a self it's a self-
soothing thing it's but it's
choking crazy you hear the audio hands
are huge dud you see those jealous crack
lobsters with that jealous of that guy
girl person not in our names okay then
who's huh I didn't expect a
followup not in they names not yeah we
don't even know your name or your
pronouns I know I know or nor do we care
well head on down let's see how Hamas
handles you yes you know what you know
what I'll save you the ticket just go to
Dearborn let's start with that let's
sponsor a trip you want to sponsor a
trip anybody want to go over there no
because that would be considered
attempted murder so let's not well you'd
be an accessory to murder if you sent
that person to Palace if they wanted to
go it doesn't matter you're not kavor
and you're not allowed to assist with
that
fine by the way I don't even know if
we've hit this yet but if at any point
during this broadcast you see
this while you're watching on head on
over to rumble that's the best place to
go all
right I don't I get that I get that it's
a tired Point like oh okay it's for p oh
yeah how do you think they would treat
you but just when you every every now
and then it does you just have to pull
back you go wait a second this is
actually happening yeah this person is
in New York and going it's wild that
person will be dragged have a truck yeah
your kind doesn't exist there yeah not
in our name they don't like your name
they don't like your name they don't
like your face uhuh they don't like your
gay face I don't like his hair to be
honest I don't like there's a lot of
things I don't like weird it's wrong to
hate though Josh uh okay we're not
supposed to hate we just don't like okay
well I'm discriminating disdain that's
fine okay A little
disc So speaking of discrimination this
is something we've talked about quite a
bit and this is also why um I think
Donald Trump uh president Trump has made
inroads with the uh with the black
community quite a bit because as you
well know the black community has a
problem with the justice system the
problem is that this this sort of
Paradigm has been presented as though
it's white versus black we do have a
problem with our Judicial System um and
it's largely about people who've been
entrenched for their lives uh versus
people who are challenging that system
it's not a race thing it's not a gender
thing and Donald Trump is obviously
experiencing that right now so we're
going to get into what is happening with
this judge and uh I would say the
outright collusion with the doj and
again how the law does not apply to all
citizens equally that is the March
toward tyranny when the law can be
applied selectively sure it starts with
auditing members of the Tea Party and
people who have uh registered Republican
voting cards okay that's what happened
with Barack Obama then it continues with
all right let's give harsher well
putting dases tuza under house arrest
with a with a breathalyzer bracelet for
giving money to a friend Senate campaign
that they lost and now we end up with um
the indictments of Donald Trump and of
course what's happened with the January
6th protesters and by that I mean people
who were not even necessarily violent or
involved with any violence getting
sentences longer than serial violent
offenders in New York so let's set this
up here first uh president Donald Trump
was issued a gag
order and this brings us to the issue of
free speech the First Amendment uh in
his ongoing federal case over the 2020
election minutes ago judge Tanya chuckin
announced from the bench that she will
impose a partial gag order on former
president Donald Trump specifically she
will prohibit all parties in the case
including Mr Trump from making or
reposting any statements publicly
targeting the special counsel his staff
the judge's staff or Court personnel and
also will prohibit statements about
potential Witnesses and the subject of
their
testimony okay I'm just the word
targeting like okay well what does that
mean he can't be like that guy's an
idiot really why not you might as well
tell a bird not to sing I
know you think you're GNA get Donald
Trump to not talk trash I know it's like
a it's like a setup yeah it almost feels
like ENT trapment think about remember
that uh uh Trevor bow Story the guy was
falsely accused of of rape he was
allowed to say anything and he wasn't
allowed to say anything he was under a
gag order that this happens all the time
he's under a whatever Sheed not through
her lawyer New York Post fake pictures
that by the way the lawyer had at the
time the fake pictures were released yep
uh was it it was uh fredman Freedman
Brian fredman who has done a lot of
these types of cases out there so you
saw that he couldn't respond until two
years later because he's under a gag
order and again we're dealing with
someone who is uh some people say former
president some people say setting
president I say sitting president
sitting sitting uh standing who is a
public figure who is undergoing right
right now he's running for office so if
you keep limiting his ability to
criticize for example government
agencies that's part of his campaign
yeah well and it's also part of his
defense like Jack Smith is out there
saying all of these things about him
right and he can say that guy's lying
that guy's full of crap that guy's
bought and paid for by DC that guy he
should be able to say that stuff because
that guy's out there saying the same
other stuff about Trump right well
here's here's the judge on the gag order
um Tanya is it Tanya chuin that sounds
close enough this is not about whether I
like the language Mr Trump uses this is
about language that presents a danger to
the administration of justice his
presidential candidacy does not give him
cart blanch to vilify public servants
who are simply doing their jobs by the
way um if you were paid you're not a
servant F the language no just you're
not a public servant this whole I went
into public service really Jo okay let
me ask you this former Vice President
Joe Biden how else would you become that
wealthy
you're an unintelligent person with no
discernable skill set so you have to
remember to this judge uh handed down
sentences and this is important because
Donald Trump wants to speak out against
the bias of this judge because that is
relevant is there proof judge handed
down these sentences to the January 6
protesters that were even more harsh
than the doj recommended right she
sentenced 11 protesters to jail when the
doj recommended no jail time think about
that the Department of Justice the
people bringing the charges on our
behalf said
no jail time for these people and she's
like N I think I'm going to give jail
time yeah and it gets worse but here let
me read a quote from her she said to
compare the actions of people protesting
mostly peacefully for civil rights to
the Mob that was trying to overthrow the
government on January so she decided to
give jail time hey mostly peaceful how
many billions in Damages with the summer
of love this is an ex again right here
is the law applied equally so she handed
out more harsh sentences okay then
recommended by the doj and now this is
relevant because the doj now is pushing
for harsher sentences for some of the uh
some of the January 6 protesters that
have already been sentenced so you have
hey these ones shouldn't get jail this
judge says no I'm going to give them
jail and now the doj the same doj is
saying hey you know the ones who you've
given un the kind of jail time that is
completely unprecedented yeah we want
more so good example uh proud boy leader
you know Enrique tario they want him to
get you're talking about decades in
prison he's already I think what is he
17 I think he's 17 years and they want
to push for more they want to now extend
it so you have this judge and the J he
didn't do anything I mean he burned down
a police station that's a good point
well look if you're going to call it
mostly peaceful protest you have to
apply that same logic to what happened
on January 6 which was way more peaceful
than what was happening with the BLM
riots not to mention Donald Trump said
be peaceful yeah words were spoken
patriotic and be peaceful sing not
supposed to burn down yes they all own
guns and they didn't bring them and they
don't even name them sideways no they
don't well for fun so let's think about
this for a second you have a guy who is
being indicted a guy who's going through
a political Witch Hunt right now
president Trump he's not going to be
able to criticize well obviously
effectively the judge the judge doesn't
want to be criticized but um the doj
special counsel Jack Smith yeah Works
Courthouse staffers or workers potential
Witnesses like uh Bill bar right former
former Attorney General then you have
Mark Millie former VP Mike Pence oh the
guy who keeps talking trash on De think
about that yeah he's running in a
primary against Mike Pence and he's not
allowed to tarnish the reputation of
Mike Pence this is we talked about is he
going to be able to um is he going to be
able to campaign from jail they're
trying to do it without doing it at this
point before he even reached any kind of
a verdict it's great you can now no
longer address the institutions and the
people and platforms who will be
attacking you most yeah I'm look if if
the judge wanted to issue an order
saying you can't go after people who
work at the courthouse or the judge
right now for now roughly the judge I
think is kind of fair game because she's
in public life to some degree right
being the being the judge I'm okay with
leaning that direction but the rest of
these people no no no no no no this is
not how you get to do justice this is
not behind closed doors where nobody can
make the case that these people are
targeting them because they obviously
are targeting them that's what Donald
Trump would do part of his defense they
have it both ways right they have the
mug shot they have the per walk into
court then they have reporters discuss
in court but Donald Trump is not allowed
to discuss it and by the way this is all
under the guys that that uh he might
influence the jury well okay let's just
be clear here the jury isn't Biden won
92% of the vote in DC yes it's
overwhelmingly Li in DC you're not
influencing the just he's just going to
piss the jury off more this judge is not
concerned with Donald Trump influencing
the jury he's going to piss off the jury
but it will Galvanize the American
public that's the difference he is
broadcasting to an audience of the
entire nation and they want to keep this
to an audience of 92% Biden voting base
that's really what we're dealing with
now here's the thing if they think that
they can hamstring Donald Trump let's
let's kind of go through this he's been
the endorsements that this guy is seing
is on now he has even rapper uh a walk a
flame walk a Flocka Flame flock flame
walk a Flocka Flame man you almost cuss
on accident there yeah I know it's
tough inal Snoop he he should be able to
say whatever he wants about this judge
should be able to prank call the judge
hello excuse is your refrigerator
running cuz you're a you're not a
person it's not even how you end the
line but okay excuse me do you have PR
do you have Prince Albert in a can what
I have is that pipe tobacco because
you're an
[Laughter]
she to say whatever he wants just to be
clear this is a Witch Hunt can they put
him in a stockade as well yeah exactly
roll them in public flogging throw
tomatoes at them it's not carnivore
now we have other people who are
realizing this too by the way let's be
clear like Donald Trump again we've
talked about this the doj we're talking
about the justice system this is why he
has this weird Alliance that you don't
typically see with rep you may not like
him but it's a different voting base and
you see with for example everyone else
on the GOP stage in a lot of ways you
even have billionaires right now who
have been waking up this there's here's
a yeah let me before you play this clip
just remember this person that we're
about to show you super liberal did
Hillary Clinton campaign fundraisers
donate a ton of money to Joe Biden he's
the guy part owner of the Warriors who
said nobody cares about Wagers in China
that we railed against this guy also
said Trump is an idiot savant without
the Savant so that was then with this
guy and now here is him saying what he
really thinks about that Administration
let's go voter for Hillary Clinton I
voted for Joe Biden but this is the
honest assessment the guy did for the
things that he was supposed to do a good
job and for where every other president
found a way to frankly make our
situation a little bit worse
specifically around Wars he did not do
that is one's Trump derangement syndrome
causing more damage than anything that
Trump could have actually done and I
think the answer is yes because like
it's now causing us to not
see that good work and then Embrace and
extended so much of the work that
happened in that
Administration turns out to have been
right and that's what's so frustrating
for me the work on the border wall we
didn't like the messenger so we killed
the message Mr Bean's not supposed to
talk he just got of
make you get that guy
Trump when you get that guy on your side
yeah when you get that guy going you
know what guys maybe he wasn't all wrong
that that's impressive that's a win
that's why we showed you that right that
was making the rounds on social media
because it's it's important but it's
like when you get to that kind of level
of changing somebody mind somebody's
mind you know the current Administration
is screwing up royally he did not want
to say that about Donald Trump well they
want to campaign on everything except
the actual issues so when they actually
have to campaign on the issues and we'll
get to Joe Biden's campaign former Vice
President Biden um he just has to lie
yeah he just has to lie and say that
you're better off that unemployment is
you know at a record low that uh salary
that right now you're doing better than
you were before you became president no
one buys it and so you have to indict
the guy who made the country better off
people are acknowledging this you have
to indict the guy who actually had uh us
in a setting of of Peace globally when
we're talking about the International
Community you have to silence him indict
him gag order and then just campaign
enough to slip your lion and then fade
back into the darkness which brings us
while we're talking about politics and
you probably have more to say about this
than I do Gerald uh you like the
wrestling Ang here well I just don't you
respect it I just you know what I I
really hope this doesn't become the case
like Jim Jordan what happens is then
when these people become speaker they
become wieners yeah it's this it's this
devolving political
term so they're going to be voting today
on whether or not to um confirm Jim
Jordan as Speaker of the House I think
we have a clip he's known here on
Capitol Hill as a staunch supporter of
former president Donald Trump he has
pushed false claims about the 2020
election saying at one point I don't
know how you convince me that Trump
actually didn't win tonight he is moving
closer to becoming the next Speaker of
the House several members who initially
had reservations about Jordan now say
they will support him but still this
will be an uphill challenge he can only
afford to lose four Republican votes we
could see this go multiple rounds all
right so we're doing a little wager here
because it's going to happen after the
show is done broadcasting uh bring it up
here overlay L3 there Tool
Man how many rounds will it take for
Jordan and whoever uh gets I guess the
right guest you get a free merch you get
a free merch package and lock to
Gerald's Hair by the way Price is Right
rules Price is Right rules you can't go
over well you have to be right on by the
way we're we're running this poll on
social media let us know what you think
that's right it's on Twitter right on X
sorry X oh my God yeah sorry it's
everything is wrong Today Twitter X yeah
x no one says it no one says I xed out
yesterday no one says it xed out is that
a thing yeah well you I tweeted what do
you say I xed I posted on x stupid it's
aable dumb and I believe it was McCarthy
right made it 15 rounds 15 rounds to
give you context McCarthy made it 15
rounds and uh you know uh actually we
have a clip of of how it
ended I say that I mean Jake wouldn't qu
you wanted to go hey
Ray never went down
Ray you never got me down right Ray was
his assistant uh
it it better than you know the Paul Ryan
Fiasco after he was he was
[Applause]
Ed spoiler politics spares no one he
didn't make it the neck didn't even look
like it bent hit us some quick facts hit
us with some Qui quick facts here Jal
about absolutely so just so you know
like Jim Jordan he was a former NCA
wrestling champion he hosts a camp
actually I don't know what it's called I
can't remember what it is but these guys
one of the best wrestling camps that's
why his ear look like something from
Long John Sil absolutely just a little
bit of cauliflower there he's a founder
of the House Freedom caucus as well
current chairman of the house committee
on the Judiciary and he's my favorite
person to Listen to If I ever watch one
of those hearings it's usually basically
like he's your favorite person to listen
to in those hearings oh in those
hearings well no not Morgan fre not
across all platforms I'm just saying in
those hearings it's usually a big waste
of time for most people right they just
get up there and blow V8 for a minute
and try to get a good sound bite so they
can put it out and raise more money Jim
Jordan goes after people right he does
he takes no prisoners especially when he
vly disagrees with you and I really
respect that about him he does a good
job with it so um one of the things that
people may not know and this is why this
next section is important like what does
the speaker of the house actually do
right they actually control the power of
the purse they set the agenda for the
house all the spending bills and stuff
they must start in the house obviously
so it's an important position to have
somebody strong in there and he's second
in line of succession to the president
right so after after obviously of the
vice president uh you go to this guy if
he doesn't bring something to the floor
for a vote if he says that it isn't
going to make it out then it doesn't
matter what bills you have that are
trying to get out of I'd like to hear
from you guys if you would like Jim
Jordan comment below or I guess hit like
if you would like it to be Jim Jordan
you know I'm just neutral on these not
neutral I like I like Jim Jordan but the
issue is it's just politics everyone
becomes dirty at some point in time I
know it sounds cynical um a little bit I
hope that he's better than Ryan I hope
that he's better than McCarthy I hope
that he does cave to get the votes if
there's not enough support I hope he
just says you know what there's not
enough support for me let's put somebody
else up for this and I really do think
it should be somebody like Donald Trump
if it's not Jim Jordan right bring him
in let him have some fun people would
vote for him we'll see but they've got
such a slim margin I think he can only
lose four votes all right let's get to
something that a little more interesting
than Jim Jordan I don't know you guys
want me to do we want to do a deep dive
into Jim Jordan see you don't care you
said don't put that on meim Jord Jim
Jordan we got Jim Jordan here see nobody
KES I love Jim
Bo
mord we'll put together a montage of his
finest moments in 30 seconds or 45
seconds and you'll know everything you
need to know yeah there you go all right
let's go to former Vice President Biden
now to be clear not a fan uh we got
Biden here we got B so the good news is
oh he's he's been kicking off his
campaign here now he's hitting the
campaign Trail and the good for him he's
not under a gag order no he's not being
indicted well he just can't speak
whatever whatever takes the attention
off his son he gags people
yeah that's his son that's his son sorry
but the sins of the father I get
it so he's kicking it off by checking
out the crisis uh on the
border of Israel good morning on
Wednesday President Biden will visit
Israel he's coming here at a critical
moment for Israel for the region and for
the world yeah um not a moment too soon
now remember he only visited the United
States and Mexico border once let's keep
that in in mind yeah never visited uh
well we're talking about East Palestine
Ohio the train thing we're not talking
about toxic SP Palestine yeah but also
crappy yes there is no good Palestine
there is no no show me a good Palestine
there's only lesser Palestine just like
there's no good MLK Boulevard like there
a bad part of town like it's just you
just pray you're not at the intersect of
and Malcolm X Boulevard because that is
you're about to die it's a bullseye
what's your latty and longy oh you're
dead so
L and long never the first lty and long
I thought these were military terms I
was trying to you know well I never
sailed that was I thought you could
navigate by the Stars was straight that
was straight the whole time as it turns
out so before uh he did uh he departed
former Vice President Biden um he made
sure to Gaslight Americans This is what
he's doing with his campaign about the
economy uh which he has done in the past
but now he's really turned it into
hyperdrive here he is
again since I took office we created
13.9 million new jobs Across America I
can honestly say I mean this and I know
I don't look it but I've been around for
a
while I've never been more optimistic
about America's future just to remember
who in the hell we are we're the United
States of America I I thought maybe he
was just really being like double
sarcastic when he's like I know I don't
look it kind of like Tales from the
Crypt like I know I look 40 years young
you're like oh you're so smarmy Crypt
Keeper
but I was really hoping he'd mess up the
the United States of America we're from
the United States Micronesia F you know
the thing hey right now on CNN that's
Steve Irwin with a
blowout so he's making these claims
Steve
herwin was the folks can't see but uh
yeah it's a Sheila who thinks you're
invading his there is that
Sheila someone get a snake stick just
put her on
the so fighting kangaroos last night
good for you that's good that's pretty
good apparently he's not that popular in
Australia people didn't like him really
yeah I he was more of an export okay
like David Hasselhoff got it yes that
burger video is just a shame David
Hasselhoff I'm I'm mad at his kids that
they even released that so former Vice
President Biden is now making claims
about the economy he needs to do this
just enough to try and gasl let you just
enough to sort of you know okay draw
your attention over here a little but
none of it is true which brings us to
today's installment of claim versus
[Music]
Truth All right so here's the claim that
former Vice President Biden is making by
the way all references are available in
the description lit.com he tries to tell
you that wages and incomes are up this
year and wages are up after being
adjusted for inflation when I came to
office I would determined determined to
end the trickle down economy this little
stand is out well make sure I don't trip
maybe I 10 I make myself three in tall
by the way we weren't even we weren't
even looking for a screw up we were just
looking for the clip to say what he said
because there was a press release from
the White House claiming that incomes
are up by 1.2% right and we said well
it's always better with the claim Toth
to have a clip and we can't find the
clip where he doesn't screw up he just
extended 5 seconds and there's a screw
up yeah there's a screw up by the way
1.2% you don't send out a press release
on 1.2% well it's a rounding error it
gets
lost here's the
truth um the increases that you have
seen by the way don't even outpace
inflation it's not enough to fix any of
the Damage Done your purchasing power is
lower than ever so let's give you some
data incomes actually fell in 17 States
in 2022 it was flat in 29 States and
that's on top of the data that we've
already presented to you right the
annual income uh sort of the increase or
decrease uh that we've seen for example
under Donald Trump let me give you some
numbers and these are the most
significant I think because we're
talking about the average annual income
all right because the left if they don't
have this they really don't have much
and these are adjusted for inflation too
if if if they don't have this they don't
have anything they left the trend say
well you know what we we'll steal from
people and give it to you the middle
class or that's what they try and tell
you right so even if you're even if
you're not morally opposed to robbery um
you still think that at least you will
come out ahead so we have eight years of
Obama Vice President Biden then we have
really three years but let's call it
four of Donald Trump and now we have
another are two and a half at this point
yeah two and a half three-ish years
depending on the numbers that we're
using I don't know which quarterly uh
installments they're using so under
Obama the average annual income for
Americans went up in8 years
$1,043 and he started really low yeah
remember the financial crisis the
financial crisis he had a lot of room
for improvement exactly you were
starting below the basement level Donald
Trump an increase of 4,000 by the way
and that's including Co if you didn't
include Co it was increase of over
$5,000 in 3 years under his presidency
Biden it's down $4,200 when we're
adjusting for inflation wait it's
literally down $4,200 he wiped out the
gains that you made yes under Donald
Trump 2% $8,000 less yes yes because
inflation is the it's the silent killer
of your purchasing power and by the way
it's something that the former president
has been talking about for years I'm
grateful to the president and the vice
president for your trust and
confidence and to the US Senate as well
for their trust and confidence you want
to see my
inflation here we should have
listened can't believe we missed told
years awkward moments yeah which brings
us to his next claim where he's tried to
cut this off at the past and he goes I
know I'll say that income is up one
point but inflation is terrible so he's
probably planning for not him but Ken
jeanpier yes yeah so now they're trying
to tell you that don't worry about it
because now inflation is down that's the
claim
and inflation is coming down it's down
60% since last summer core inflation is
the lowest level in two years okay two
years of course is when you took office
during his presid just compared yourself
to the guy before you it's not as bad as
when it was still
me the earlier me was way worse yeah
come on man I'm doing better come on
it's no joke I'm doing better it's a
hard job I must be nice to be so perfect
know it look like I forgot you never
made a mistake for
us
I know it doesn't look like it but
inflation is down yeah that doesn't look
like it doesn't feel like it doesn't
smell like it if you if you stand on
this box you know you'll get paid more
oh this is hi I'm not going to get down
here here here's the truth here's the
truth the truth is that inflation is
still drastically outpacing income
Gaines okay crazy 2023 the family median
income uh is only up like we said 1.2%
okay but the average monthly inflation
is up
5.97%
5.97 most generous number we could give
by the way yeah by mean most
conservative it's not six so that's good
yes it's not six not six good
yeah bring that graph bring that overly
back up really quickly before when I was
here it was more than six was and now
it's now it's less than six round two or
three and i' I like I like less than six
more than more than six come on it's
twice as high as the highest
inflation say
that's what you say no that's the gr
that's something you that's something
you say come on
man perfect so for all you middle class
Americans uh former Vice President Biden
has a message for those folks I don't
care if you think I'm Satan
reincarnated nailed it okay he doesn't
care you know what you do have to
respect someone who owns it that's true
and Satan reincarnated would own it well
that's a little weird because he was
never alive to die to be reincarnated I
I just think it's Satan incarnate yeah
he would be more like a possession
possess little different that'd be a
horrible possession I I feel like even
Satan's like nah that's not my that's
not me guys that's not how I
roll I forgot about that guy to be
honest Satan no no he's saying that
about Biden that's my Satan impression
by the way it's very it sounds a lot
like Josh yeah it does it does sound no
it's a little different it's got more of
a New York thing like who's this guy
well you know the devil you know is
better than the devil in your shoes
hey come on there's there's a you guys
complaining about there's an Indian in
the Cupboard
man it's right
there can't see him it's so little I
don't know watch out that's happened to
all the Cherokees I got really small
when I was a boy got really small and we
moved him off reservations in the
cupboards here's another truth oh thank
God 6 % of Americans are still living
paycheck to paycheck under Biden okay
earning less than 50,000 a year 76% of
Americans right now earning 50,000 a
year to 100,000 a year that's about 62%
of America and they're living paycheck
to paycheck these are just the people
living paycheck to paycheck yeah and
here's my question what kind of changes
have you had to make by the way just to
deal with the effects of the Biden offic
right now this is a genuine question
yeah I think a lot of people have second
jobs and third jobs these days and then
he's claiming unemployment yeah ex he's
claiming oh I created jobs no no no you
you did create jobs that I'm I'm doing
extra jobs so I can make the same amount
of money and then a lot of the jobs that
outside of that are are fake think about
it 87,000 new IRS not agents will get
fact checked employees emplo employes by
the way by the way that's you're paying
their salary so they owe you a thank you
don't let them tell you that they're
public servants they're public thieves
thank you for your service by the way
the people making over
$100,000 that are living PID 45% of
people live uh making over $100,000 of
living PID
45% yeah of people making six figures
well living paycheck to paycheck that's
how expensive things are now under this
Administration well also it's a separate
Point people aren't being responsible
sure I agree shouldn't be living
paycheck to paycheck if you're making
six figures I understand that I get it
but 45% of people that's just not good
it is not good well you'll look here's
the thing if we had a drastic salary
increase that would again really just
kind of spur more inflation because the
salary increases and we've had it we've
given raises here at this company we did
it last year we said that it's the
inflation uh it's the inflation raise
and so uh you know it's going to be uh
25% um to do a part you're so generous
yeah I know that's what they call me but
it's outpacing inflation so dramatically
so even if your salaries were to go up
but they're not it still wouldn't
increase your purchasing power so it's
it's a double aiming and by the way what
does this mean when we go into you know
one of the most important indicators of
the economy home ownership this is
massive okay the average uh price of a
home right now in the United States is
$416,000 okay so that's up quite a bit
but here's something that's more more
important again as it relates to your
purchasing power the average 30-year
mortgage interest rate in this country
is
7.8% that's
7.8% that's Co up too so under Donald
Trump that was 3% so to give you an idea
let's let's take the average house
$416,000 assuming a 20% down payment
okay under Trump your monthly payment
would have been about
$1,700 okay under Biden
$2,700 wow it's $1,000 more per month
and it doesn't just affect new home
buyers it affects people who want to
sell houses as well because you have to
sell your house and you don't get the
same kind of house if you purchase
another house you basically have to
downgrade you are downgrading so even if
your house went up in value because of
the change in the interest rates it's
what they call the golden handcuffs you
have people who want to retire who want
to downsize into smaller houses but
there's really no net benefit this
happens with a lot of older people I
mean know if you have like some
grandparents something like that maybe
they live in a house where you now
they're empty nesters they say ah this
is you know 3,000 feet we don't really
need it we'd like to sell this which is
part of people's retirement plan by the
way a lot of people we're going to sell
it downgrade maybe live in a condo oh
wait a a second now the ranch Now The
Bungalow now the condo is just as
expensive as that house when you bought
it with the interest payment not to
mention when you when the interest rates
are up the Market's down because
nobody's buying yeah value of your house
goes down because we got Black Rock we
got Vanguard buying up all the single
single family units and Elizabeth Warren
says that they're too big to fail hey
fantastic did you just see this just was
breaking this morning a control room you
can bring it up Bank of America I think
what do they have in their net losses
this last year I think it's $110 billion
somewhere around there they just closed
I believe 40 something Banks but the
fundamentals are sound yeah guys bring
that up it was just trending this
morning they're Sounder than when they
weren't sound when they were said to be
sound before yeah Wells Fargo has closed
a bunch as well Chase only closed I
think three but uh yeah so that is Wells
Fargo even still around yeah they merge
with wovi or something there you go oh
yeah 31 billion in losses yeah and they
just closed a a record number of banks
we gave you more money than that how'd
you lose it all Y and this is uh due to
you think it's due to lack of uh Home
Loans going out or mortgages well no I
think it's just in general right you're
talking about these people they manage a
lot of you know they manage a lot of uh
pensions things like that right and so
they're all kind of different equities
right and bonds and they've just lost
money right in their Investments but
then they end up closing the banks and
you end up bailing them out it's too big
to fail why would they do any
differently by the way why would these
Banks do any differently so you get
screwed in the mortgage you get screwed
on your income you get screwed with
inflation you're purchasing power but
the good news is you get to bail out the
banks the good news is you get to bail
out the airlines the good news is you
get to bail out the American auto
manufacturers while they about the
they about how the middle class is
shrinking because you aren't paying for
them enough just to be clear it's not a
conservative stance to be Pro bank it's
not certainly not if they're receiving
never- ending bailouts we' we've
effectively socialized the Banks without
socializing the banks and we
Consolidated it too when all these Banks
were failing we basically all right you
got got to buy those assets you got to
buy those assets now we've made bigger
Banks across the board that have more
assets that are ready to go under
potentially and then there are social
problems sociological problems that
contribute to this economy and this is
where when we talk about the American
dream we're not just talking about your
salary we're not just talking about the
size of your house we're not just
talking about getting two weeks vacation
we are talking about the changes that
have taken place and this has been
shipped Away by the Left Right the
nuclear family this idea um uh that uh
well black lives matter says that the
nuclear family is a white patriarchal
construct whoops they also support Hamas
so you know there's that but uh younger
people are not getting married and so
these are single inome households let me
give you some numbers Millennials only
44% are married compare that to
Generation X was 53% Boomer 61% the
silent generation 81% they just didn't
tell you about it then we
have then we go to gen Z I know that
they're younger but they still are we're
talking about people under the age of 30
right 30 would be pretty young to get
married this is a new thing right now it
is known as second adolescence just to
be clear this idea that you don't get
married you don't start having a family
until you're into your 30s That's A New
Concept now you may think that in
today's society you have to fine but
let's just be clear that's not the way
to build uh wealth or certainly it's
going to be a lot harder if you're in a
single- income household single men
under the age of 30 Generation Z it's
63% wow and then women under 30 uh only
34% of them are single which I know that
that that number is kind of startling it
actually caught our researchers off
[Music]
guard
lesbians simple answer makes sense they
can't all be gems now
science 63% versus 34% how do you what's
the what's the population differential
as far as like men versus women in
generation pretty close so how does that
how does that figure out well so when
how many gay couples are getting married
no I don't think it's that necessarily I
think it's that women are finding men
under 30 completely unattractive and not
ready for marriage and they're Mar over
30 oh okay so and men are like he no no
but they're more single women so it
means that the men under 30 are marrying
older women no no no no no no well I
don't know what the men under 30 who
they are marrying you're right maybe
they're marrying a little it's 63% of
men under the age of 30 are single only
30 34% of women right so the men are
probably marrying more older women as
well as cuz there's still plenty of
single women they're not getting married
it's like a ven diagram of this where
things intersect I don't know where it
is I guess oh sorry they're okay well
the point is they're marrying older guys
I have no idea ladies are marrying older
guys because they're not mature the
second adolescence thing it plays into
it they're waiting more money you know
like wi they get better with time I
never learned
Chom come on got to find the coine
tangent yeah I guess that makes sense
yeah yeah so 63% of men are single
because women don't want to marry them
under 30 they want to wait and women are
getting married to older men so yeah and
then we have to hear someone on The View
say do you think it's do you think it's
okay for an age differential and they go
I you know I think it's okay if a woman
dates an older guy but then they just
on a guy who dates a younger woman
you're a creep it's like really I don't
I don't think so so they bring on to
their shows he like oh no no I like
dating younger women why perky tits yeah
like you're a creep no one bats an eye
at a young woman dating an older guy
it's always a guy yeah no one's talking
about Leonardo DiCaprio's all of his
girlfriends they talk about him well to
him if you're over 25 you're dead yeah
yeah
he's been
gerric so here's the good news when
you're talking about your mortgage
though former Vice President Biden's
he's working on making it more
accessible to uh everyone oh good oh
sorry did I say everyone I meant illegal
immigrants that's everyone yeah yeah so
bring up the overlay this is a this
right here it says the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau and justice
department reminds financial
institutions that all credit applicants
are protected from discrimination
regardless of their immigration status
what if the immigration status is oh
he's not
here that seems like it would be an
important point on the list it seems
like is it possible that you won't be in
this country to pay this loan again
tomorrow yeah can you just default on
this loan yeah there's just a cloud
shaped Sombrero of where the illegal
immigrant used to
be meanwhile they're like Mr fires sign
your credit looks like well that's
your own fault but I'll be here to not
pay it yes hey it's almost like we've
been here before
leverage right putting leverage on these
financial institutions you better you
better give these loans out you hey
don't discriminate Fanny May Freddy Mack
we're talking about we're talking about
Frank DOD yeah you better give out these
loans well hold on a second they can't
they can't pay it back don't worry the
government will guarantee it but you
have to give out loans to people who
can't pay it back because this is this
is racial Equity I guess all right fine
so you're going to ensure that I get
paid back it's guaranteed no matter what
yeah yeah we'll just take it from the
taxpayer all right and then we'll just
we'll just call you a predatory lender
wait what was that doesn't matter we
just we blame it on you but you're not
blame it on me I wouldn't just to be
clear government this is a hypothetical
just to be clear government I am the
bank my job is to lend people money and
I make money when they pay it back with
interest uhhuh so I would never lend
money I would never provide this loan to
someone who I know could not pay it back
we understand unless you're guaranteeing
me that the taxpayer will pay me back
yes that's what we're saying all right
well then I guess it doesn't make just
give money out to everybody because I
make money no matter what absolutely
right then we'll just blame you and call
you a predatory lender see that's the
part I have a problem with it gets a
little bit worse it gets a little bit
worse because when you're paying back
your mortgage you're paying almost all
interest initially so when they get
bailed out they get bailed they've got
all that interest payment going to it
but it didn't pay down the balance of
your mortgage and so they get bailed out
on the entire thing MH it's worse so
they made a bunch of money off of you
for whatever payments you did make and
then they get the entire nut back
because the government has to come in
and take care of them and then Tom celic
has the nerve to sell you
mortgage I'm a little down on my luck if
I thought this was a scam I wouldn't be
here that's the only reason he's I like
you Tom celic but I don't like the
reverse Morgan and by the way former
vice president bid he seems to think
this is all just one big joke you know
SC you guys have no sense of humor man
yeah what is he talking to people in
Gaza like he's on trip jeez when did
Biden start doing standup that's awesome
and you know he just he was there in
front of a PL he's like I got to wear my
Aviator if I'm want to be here in an air
base like
Maverick what's my call sign poopster
where's my Goose oops just trying to
hide that he's actually asleep yeah so
no your income is not up inflation is up
far more than they want you to believe
the housing market is teetering right
now as far as and I don't mean that
there's going to be the same kind of
housing crash just to be clear uh as
there was in 2008 however the housing
market is not healthy the fundamentals
of the economy are not healthy this
economy is worse off than it was under
Donald Trump just like the United States
is worse off in the International
Community again this goes down to this
election is your life any
better and that's the that is when you
discuss this with people in your life on
a daily basis is your life better after
close to three years of Biden yeah is it
better I I can't think of you know what
i' I'd like for you to play devil's
advocate here in the comments let's try
and think of one metric where it is
better mean X's don't
count cuz it's not tweets anymore at
least the property tax is down yeah is
it oh no it's not oh I was like okay
it's totally not I appreciate that
Tim so wait a second I'm not renting no
no no you purchased it uhhuh but I still
get to pay effectively forever yeah and
if I don't you'll take it away from me
how is that un how is that not
unconstitutional no it totally is but
it's mine though it's my property yeah
no no no you got to pay for schools
except for what you have to pay for now
I understand the state States largely
are the ones who detered property taxes
I understand they are and we should do a
story on that are you anti-pry taxes I'm
very much anti-pry taxes no property
taxes at all uh you got to have some way
to fund schools but not this yeah so I
solve the problem you know by fixing the
actual problem property taxes are not
the problem they're a symptom of the
problem I'd be okay with the one time
you're not saying you're going to blow
up schools I'm going to get rid of them
oh how are you going to get rid of no
public education he's going to eradicate
them I'm going to I'm going to do a a
sale we're going to sell all the schools
and all the properties and all the
school buses and everything that we own
we should not be in this business to
private Enterprises
going to not put the taxer on the hook
for funding schols when they suck well
just let me know well that's the Federal
Department of Education no no no that's
you're saying even State Departments of
Education you think there should be no
no State the state can have a Department
of Education to oversee the Private
Industry schools that are out there like
Charter Schools right now that do better
just make sure that when you when you
close them down just let me know if
you're doing a fire sale because I need
some rebar you yeah I just don't I just
don't want to waste yeah don't forget
that copper either really hard to get
the CO the wall oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
just by the way um speaking of which you
might want to get your car taken in
because you might be missing a catalytic
converter yeah I've been here that's not
nice at all I mean the warning is nice
but I mechanic steal my catalytic
converter really yes
what that's insane I was poor aren't he
was mechanic who came to your house he's
like I come to you I was like this
almost seems too good to be
true aren't there better ways for
mechanics to screw you than stealing I
was a teenager they've been doing it for
decades and then the next mechanic is
like yeah you have no catalytic
converter like what he goes yeah you
didn't have one of those like backyard
mechanics did like yeah I did he goes ah
there's your problem there's a whole
bunch of rare minerals are worth a lot
of money he probably stole it well can I
get another one he's like you can't
afford it it's worth more than the
car well now what do I do ah you know
you're Stones you're not going to pass
the emissions test so you should
probably kill
yourself he was a SM he was a SM me he
was a SM me mechanic and he goes yeah
you're a white male so nobody cares any
yeah a door to door to door mechanic
I've never heard of that yeah they go to
your yeah they go to which is a good in
theory it is but you have no way of
checking or tracking them down no not at
all there is no location to go to yeah
all right he just brought enough tools
to take the
cataly yeah like a wrench I found the
problem man I'll be back a Victorinox
Swiss multi-tool wow you are
efficient only $20 huh I it's a steal of
a
deal sorry that's happened man it's oh
it happens all the time
happens all the time cuz we don't know
now Tim feels bad for you I was a kid I
didn't know I didn't know anything he
felt bad for your 190 I thought I knew
enough about cars because I knew how to
change my oil so felt really
accomplished I can change my oil I can
change a I'm not going to be able to fix
something with the alternator I even
changed a starter really yeah that was
it that led to your problem with a
catalytic converter guess that guy never
opened the
hood and what do you do it underneath
the car Ah that's weird like I get to
the alternator underneath the car yeah
all you need is swi armor knife and a
pair of
Clippers good enough for
me show are you sure you don't don't
tell me to do my job get I'm sorry I'm
sorry my white guilt is kicking in
continue please sorry for the oppression
you going to watch me the whole time no
I'll go inside yeah yeah man it's weird
if you watch me why don't you leave yeah
yeah take about an hour or two can't
work Under Pressure
yeah and while you're at give me give me
an give me a lemonade while you're at
and just get go away for a while okay
yes sir you got a bag can fit this
cataly converter in it all these other
cataly converters I stole are filling
this bag are you going to take it back
to your shop and fix it and bring it
back to my car yeah it's like a it's
like a Cindy lho in the Grinch I'll fix
it up there and bring it back down here
oh wow you really are you're efficient
using your
space I love the idea of a grinch
mechanic you're sleeping with a
catalytic inerter
beep he's got a little dog with
him anyone out there look comment I
don't feel like such an idiot I was a
kid I didn't know did you know that was
a huge scam they stealing your catalytic
converters I would have kept driving I
would have not even noticed just
apparently it's also why you can't just
like run a run a car in your garage you
know with the exhaust because a
catalytic converter so I guess a lot of
failed suicide attempts I have no idea
if that's true oh interesting huh it
scrubs the air I'll give it a try
Goodbye cruel world better hope you had
a bad mechanic that's a real Cru World
won't even let him kill just an awkward
breakfast dad why do you look
sleepy what were you doing in the garage
there's some idiot with a Tesla that
tried
it I've been in this garage for 3 days
it's ends up playing that video game
with a steering
wheel I'm here guess things aren't so
bad after all it's got a video game I
want to live gets hit by a cyber truck
ah okay so let's go down now to it took
us a while to get warmed up before we
got sick silly and I'm sorry now I'm not
I'm sorry let's go to no let's not be
sorry apologize for nothing sorry oh God
yeah Canadians are the
worst so we have an exclusive here and
this is what you help support with mug
club by the way is not just the other
you know you have Alex Jones of course
on Freddy you have the Hodge twins now
you have Brian Ken you have a full
additional like 50% I guess it's almost
100% increase yeah of show this show
every single day uh we're bringing on
more and more content but also you know
mug Club undercover we get to send
people out to different events and we
are actually working a big story right
now that I I can't tell you about
because you're a stranger but uh the
amount of work and do show them some
love the Mud Club undercover unit
because they don't get a lot of credit
since they have to be undercover so this
one is a little bit different because uh
Ginger Snap did go down to a rally and
this is a pro Hamas rally to be clear
not just Pro Palestine but at this point
when they when they elected Hamas I
don't really know uh what the difference
is so as we move into this let's first
take a look at uh the
[Music]
rally
oh I'm sorry is that the that was the
wrong was that the wrong clip wait I
don't know was that the right clip it
was the right clip I think it was the
right guys was that the right clip I
think it was the right clip looked like
it look like look like Dallas okay so no
that is the right
clip no it's theong it's the wrong clip
was okay well then sorry here's a here's
I guess a collage of what we're about to
go through that was the wrong clip no
wrong wrong clip here's the right
clip 392 I preach in many states I'm not
going to argue with you I'm not going to
argue with you the
the about the
B you cannot grab his stuff grab it I
just shut it off well you can't do that
either you can't touch anything to do
learn a new lesson but he can St
disrespecting myet or
else let's say we start last Saturday
what was to blame for that and then
what's happened since the the current
the current state to blame would be
Israel however we recognize that hamas's
influence is there and retaliation to
the occup
done by Israel when you said the US has
as much complicity on its hands as
Israel if what happened to Israel is
Justified with the same thing happening
here to Americans be justified if you're
aiding somebody to slaugher
you what does that make you
[Music]
complicit and uh so here to talk about
it and more though next time we probably
should send out more security yeah with
d Snap Lane uh you were there this was
this weekend I was it was Sunday
afternoon around Dallas you just had to
make a game day decision and you went
down I Casey text me uh Yakuza text me
about 2 minutes before it was stting
he's like hey you getting some footage
I'm like I guess I will and so I ran
down there did you go down there no I
was I was doing oh okay so to put him in
I'm not an idiot internal I was thinking
just like look out the window take some
photos I didn't know you were going to
dive into it but hey props to you my guy
Oh you mean because you thought he was
closer in proximity than you yeah all
right thanks for doxing him well you
know not like not like Hamas is gonna
have a reason to all right well I'm
sorry understand well you know what
we're already here so uh you were there
at this rally and by the way I think we
have a clip too from uh I don't know if
we have it from Dearborn something going
on there of course in my uh home state
of Michigan um what did you experience
there we are going to roll some of the
uh the raw Clips by the way on X you can
follow me there today because we have a
lot of footage right so you had some
some things that you some signs I guess
that were pretty disconcerting yeah
there were some it was
interesting talking to people because
when you would ask them flat out is this
a pro Hamas righ do you support Hamas
they would always couch it with well no
we don't support violence but if you
look at how Israel's handled the
situation over the past you know 75
years you can understand why Hamas did
what they did that's generally the
sentiment right and well that's the idea
of when we've talked about this I think
is the ceasefire which is if you just
raped somebody you just killed somebody
you don't get to call for a ceasefire
that is support of the rapist and the
murderer and uh they've been do I mean
they've been trying to do this by the
way in whitewash films for for years
right Marin I'd knock that off if I was
you die you
mother hey ceasefire ceasefire everyone
calm down hey
ceasefire calm down
guys it doesn't have the same impact we
might need a couple of the ceasefire
guys come to America here pretty
soon so yeah they'll always say that
well yeah but the interesting thing was
too even some were even more I guess
blatant than that when you say is this a
pramas rally they say we're not going to
speak to you I say just say it's not a
pramas rally yeah we're not making any
comments well it kind of seems like
you're making a comment right yeah
exactly just like when they say what
about they go what about the Israel
Target women and children they go well
if they do that I condemn it and by the
way uh I haven't seen it but if they do
it of course I condemn the targeting of
women and
children yeah condemned now will you
condemn Hamas oh you were playing word
games yeah you know they targeted the
women and children with leaflets that
said hey we're going to bomb Hamas which
you happen to be right next to because
they tend to locate themselves next to
women and children in places that women
and children frequent like playgrounds
in schools and you know mosques and
things like that but and and I got the
paper cut yes that's true and I'm sorry
about that Habib my bad but then Hamas
blocks the exits and blocks people from
actually fleeing from northern Gaza and
even just you were speaking with them we
we'll run some more Clips but the signs
that they put out there still aren't
good no especially yeah I mean we can
look at some of them they were very
blatant as to what their cause was yeah
let's bring this up this is a this is a
sign from a kid it says Israel is
killing children like me okay so a mom
puts a little kid there I that so much
and the kid smiled and gave me a thumbs
up I was like all right is I okay sure
he doesn't even know what's on the sign
said hold the well I asked one guy I
went up to him and it said Israel is an
apar State I said what is this he goes
uh I go what's aparti he goes I learned
about in government class but I really
can't explain it oh okay good can you
name me one place in the world
associated with theth that was one of
the five white people that was at the
rally besides me so I was say there was
that guy with the uh the pubic hair
mustache John socialism for
Palestine couple more signs that were
pretty uh here's another one this is a
sign that says if you are silent when
Israel kills Palestinians remain silent
when Palestinians defend themselves ah
so they see what happened October but
exactly October
7th take that same logic no no no but if
you take that same logic you went and
killed innocent civilians on purpose
targeted you weren't targeting IDF you
weren't targeting the military
leadership you weren't targeting the
elected officials or even batteries of
operations you targeted innocent
civilians so maybe you should just shut
the hell up when when when they go and
Target Hamas the people that did it this
is what really tips right this is what
really tips their hand like well then
you should just be quiet when the
Palestinians defend themselves okay so
that's where I don't know if you spoke
with this person this sign probably not
it's like so you believe they were
defending themselves when they targeted
hundreds of innocent women and children
people that were in the country just to
go to a concert yeah well it's just like
it's it's there only killing all the
Jews of our political leaders saying
they need space to destroy right Max
talking about black lives matter who by
the way also endorse amas they make
great bed fellows uh they say these
people aren't stopping they should stop
these people are killing innocent women
and children there's a huge difference
between killing to protect your women
and children and killing while hiding
behind your women and children we're
going to go defend ourselves get your
parachutes yeah we're going to we're
going to defend ourselves you think do I
need like a bulletproof vest no we'll
just grab a baby carriage put it in
front of
you so this is all this this amalgamate
like you talked about it's not just and
this is just like we saw people were
surprised with black lives matter it's a
socialist organization right where this
also transitioned into not just
Palestine not just Hamas but uh anti-
capitalism yes for some reason there's
always a socialist that wants to blame
capitalism and Israel I guess because
they have a nice economy it's uh
antithetical to
socialism Arab Israelis have higher GDP
than yeah what people kept saying you
know we want a free state where everyone
can be free I'm like you mean like Arabs
in Israel yeah people like that exact
situation you mean like Arabs only in
places like Israel 20% of the countries
Arabs like what are we doing here no
they mean like Iran or Iraq or No
Sa well did you see the Irish Prime
Minister he was like if you were to have
a lion if we were to have a lion here at
the Irish at the airport I can't
remember the name of theeland Ireland
because we would have a line here that
would to say okay if you're white or
european you can go here but if you're
Jewish you have to go here you would
call that a partti that's what you're
doing you have a separate line for
security for Arabs well hold on a second
let's just be let's be honest Lou it's
not just because they're Arab it's
because you know they're surrounded by
people who want to kill them yeah and
they're always yelling Allahu abbar
Allah Akbar you know the streets ofex
death to Israel eradication of the Jews
that's the reason they might double
check your passport and they did that to
he's a little pissed off in projecting
they did that to you in the 1980s
because you guys were trying to blow up
Parliament right okay the guys with a
funny accent had a little extra
screening yes because you were blowing
stuff up so this is sorry this is one of
the signs you were saying and then you
can fill me on anything that I missed
here uh well yeah and Israel aparte to
end capitalism
fine there's always one idiot this is
kind of the most telling one like this
is and and it's not like these people
were inherently mean to me or anything
but they do have an ideology and a goal
that if you kind of bring it to its
logical conclusion it is not a it's not
a peaceful ending right and they believe
that God is on their side in this
Conquest here's a yeah here's a sign to
that effect says Dear Israel you cannot
and then not is bigger than cannot
cannot break an OM that fears Allah more
than they fear you in other words okay
you cannot break you're talking about
break who Hamas Hamas is their enemy
when they say Palestinians defend
themselves okay has there been a single
palestin when you're talking about
you're talking about Hamas so when
you're saying Palestinians defend
themselves you guys are equating Hamas
and this is the thing I constantly hear
from people on the right or or certainly
people who are pro Israel saying you
know we do need to see that there is a
difference between Hamas and certainly
the Israeli Ambassador Hamas and the
Palestinian people the greatest enemy of
the Palestinian people is Hamas it's
people who are pro Palestine who don't
delineate they say when Palestinians
defend themselves this is an attack from
Hamas it's the easiest out that you
could take yeah just condemn Hamas yeah
every one of the people in Gaza right
now who are fleeing and complaining like
they're trying to bomb us they're trying
to they're making us flee look I
understand that's a terrible situation
to be in but there's a simple solution
get rid of Hamas you brought him in get
rid of Hamas e even the pro Palestine we
like Jewish people we want a peaceful
state so or like a one state where we
can all live together I ask him Point
Blank okay so let's see and you'll see
this more in the video if we were to
agree we all make Israel Palestine one
state Jews and Arabs live there together
Palestinians peacefully can we just say
no Hamas in that state he goes well
they're democratically elected so you
have to let democracy rule there it is
he says it you know he says it with his
own words and he's the most he's kind of
the more peaceful the more reasonable
person do we have that clip oh we have
the full video that you'll be able to
see on Twitter okay Crowder so we're
going to run that we're going you know
what we'll run it here I guess at the
end of the show before we go to uh to
mug Club so you can watch it I just
don't want to have to fit in like
minutes uh and then you can watch on X
sorry you can watch all these completely
raw but do we do we have time do we want
to go through the increased risks of
attack right now I I don't think we need
to just go through the one thing skip
the clip on on Christopher Ray I think
that stuff's important but we can put it
in another show for every I wanted to
put this in there and I agree the only
part is the last part that's important
is you see this in America you see this
in a city like Dallas which is a
conservative City by a lot of measures
compared to other big cities and you can
have 5,000 6,000 people and even if a
small percentage of those is radicalized
which we know that's 1% that's still a
hefty portion of people that want to see
the downfall of the society that they
live in right well and and I think one
of the most important things to look at
is that this these numbers of terrorists
at the border when they're not trying to
apprehend them so to give you an idea
here in 2023 there was a record 151
people on the terror watch list on the
terror watch list just to be clear now
there are plenty of terrorists who
aren't on the watch list yet right yeah
they haven't made the ranks and by the
way you know they're trying to downplay
these numbers of course because they're
also not really apprehending as many
people at the border as they should be
so let's look at this number by the way
under Donald under 2018 2019 2020 under
Donald Trump you had 6 3 and three
respectively as far as people
apprehended at the border who were on
the terror watch list and by the way
they were apprehending more people and
sending them back than they are right
now under Biden 2021 15 2022 98 and in
2023 151 people on the terror watch list
so far and the numbers you were talking
about if you take uh Muslims globally
and you take that do we I don't know if
we have that there in the overlay the
poll of Muslims who believe that
violence against civilians is at least
sometimes warranted that's 150 198
million people sorry and then if you
take the percentage of Muslims who
believe that violence against civilians
is often warranted that's still well
over 50 million people4 million people
believe that that's that's that number
should tell you everything 198 PE 198
million people if they get together and
form a country and form an army that is
a formidable foe who thinks yeah
absolutely I'd put my dollars towards
that I think that's absolutely fine
against civilians right civilians the
people that were the thing that Israel
is being accused of doing right now
going after civilians 198 million
Muslims around the world think that's
fine well those aren't civilians those
are Palestinians defending themselves
yes sorry Hamas Hamas because they're
democratically democratically elected I
mean you know there was unev I mean if
you trust Dominion but that's a whole
separate
thing I think there's a Palestinian my
pillow Mike Lindell
yeah yeah they don't get there they
don't get their Sil from Hamas was never
elected that was the Ghost of Hugo
Chavez
but the last thing that really blows my
mind is this circular logic that they
have is okay it's America's fault
because they support Israel they're
creating these refugees but America
should be the one to take these refugees
in even though they have decried many
times that they hate us but we should
bring them in speaks to this I got a 24
second clip here of King Abdullah II of
Jordan refusing Jordan's pretty close to
Israel right yeah I think it's pretty
Egypt not only that Jordan historically
has something to do with Israel you know
that trying to wipe them off the face of
the map when they teamed up with their
buddies they lost okay do play
this clip no refugees in Jordan no
refugees in Egypt that is a red line uh
because I think that is the plan by
certain of The Usual Suspects to try and
create de facto issues on the ground
this is a situation of humanitarian
Dimension that has to be dealt inside of
Raza and uh and and the West Bank and
not to try and push the Palestinian I
challenge and their future onto other
people's shoulders which is exactly what
the Iranians want to do exactly by the
way the their future rested on your
shoulders initially because there was
really no Palestinian people until you
guys created it and by the way you're
what would you like Israel to do what
what what Pro Palestinian problem are
you talking about there's no problem
there's just people being oppressed and
living in the largest outdoor prison in
the world from what I've heard so I
thought these were peaceloving people
that just wanted their own State and you
won't take any of them in they can't go
to your country and apparently you speak
for Egypt as well because they can't go
to Egypt both you guys have a border
with Egypt and Gaza there they could
open the gates today and let people
flood in the refugees we could send in
help you no black Liv matter supports
it's it's the same Playbook where you go
out there you smack a cop around you
take an eightball and then yeah and then
you go run the cameras run the cameras I
mean how many times have we seen that
like Mike Brown punch a cop grab his gun
and then hands up don't shoot and it's a
lie what they do is they create their
own problems they creat by Hamas they're
created by the Arabic World they don't
help them they go look at Israel look at
Israel look at Israel look at Israel
they want this problem to stay there
they do not want this issue to be solved
with Gaza because this is the rally cry
for everybody to go look how bad Israel
is look what they do to the people of
Gaza and then we go hey you could fix
that no no no no no no no we don't want
the Palestinian problem in our lands but
look how bad Israel is well you know
it's a virtue signal when it is the
American liberal that is the biggest
supporter of the Palestinian quote
unquote people when the the Sunni the
Sunni Saudis who share a faith directly
with the Palestinians when Muhammad bin
Salman is like no fim we don't want them
get rid of them yeah let's be friends
with Israel instead it's unbelievable
yeah they create their problems and they
want you to and look I understand that
it's more complicated than just okay a
good side and a bad side but at this
point look I'm just going to be honest
here can you believe they cut water and
electricity yeah yeah I can do you know
what war is and by the way we certainly
consider it an act of War even if we
talking about a conflict over land
before this okay I get it but do
you know what war looks like you killed
seeven I think it was that day the first
day was 700 right it was 700 something
civilians well over a thousand now and
now you're now you're surprise you're
surprised they shut down and by the way
90% of the water is not controlled by
Israel just to be clear Hamas is in
control of a lot of that so why don't
you have water hey why don't you have
pipes oh you use them to turn it into
missiles I'm I'm not going to condem
Nation if they're at War for not
providing the people with whom they're
Waring water you shut that our Wi-Fi can
you imag how dare you it's like it's
like after Pearl Pearl Harbor we're
supposed to go and deliver deliver
Evon it's War we're so far removed from
they were going to they sent the wrong
plane the the wrong plane it's Ozark
Trail not the anola gay what this is not
Aquafina no you go tastes like wet
pennies this is that's for a look I and
I I I agree with you my my problem right
now is the Palestinian people who if
there are just a mass majority of people
who really don't know anything about
this they're getting played yes by all
sides Hamas is playing you because
they're they don't care about you
they're just using you you're a useful
idiot Egypt Jordan Saudi Arabia Iran
Iraq Syria turkey none of those people
care about you they're just using you as
well the rest of the world you could
expand that out into Russia and
potentially even China China's got their
hands deep in keep in mind just
yesterday what was trending was Israel
is attacking these areas of God and
they're not allowing people to leave you
just heard it Egypt said no Jordan said
no in other words these other countries
are very clear they they are not taking
them in all it would take if you were
saying that Israel isn't allowing them
to leave what you mean is Israel is not
allowing them to go into Israel okay it
just takes one other Nation to take them
in there's not
one so it's all Israel's fault not one
think about that for a second share the
same religion you think the Iranians who
are the biggest backers of them might
want to take them in but this is the
Palestinians are a a chest piece for the
Iranians to wield against the Saudis
this is what this is this is a proxy
conf stay stay and give us a little bit
more of that for Mud Club that's right
do we want to roll the clip in before we
go to Mud Club I think we should roll
the clip okay roll the clip we're going
to so this is the clip between the uh
the Muslim and the Christian preacher
going out okay so we're going to roll
this and by the way then after that if
you are watching right now on Rumble
click this button to join mug Club where
we are going to discuss actually um more
so the history of Christianity and Islam
and some of the red herrings and some of
the myths that maybe you believe but
this is an interesting conversation J
snap was there I'm glad you came back in
one piece too and this will roll
straight into uh mug Club I have to go
put an icy hot patch on my neck there's
only two ways you hurt your neck let's
watch the Bible the Quran says inah
392 I preach in many states I'm not
going to argue with you I'm I'm not
going to argue with you the the say
about the Bible
[Music]
no don't do
that
not you can't tou anybody's equipment
that's why they're here why do you think
the police are
here what he wants
to touch you cannot grab his stuff I
grab it I just shut it off well you
can't do that either you can't touch
anything learn a new lesson but he stop
disrespecting or
else we get it frustrating like we we
don't agree with what he's doing cuz
obviously he's trying to get a stir out
of you guys right now but he our
Sergeant is bringing up on you can't
watch him and he touched me he literally
hurt my hand so we're going to talk
about death on him
sorry not sorry he disrespected my
Propet and heed me touching I don't
care unfortunately here you can
disrespect whatever do I do I agree with
what people say about us sometimes
absolutely not however they have the
right to say that he has the right to
say that here it may be disrespectful
and it it may
bring strong feelings against him and it
may bring some other stuff I love the
Dallas
Police don't
blame
to
do right but it doesn't make it right
right he could have got arrested just as
much as you could have got arrested do
you want do do I want to arrest you
today absolutely not do I want to arrest
him I absolutely do not disrespecting
people well you can disrespect whoever
as long as you don't make it
physical no one made it physical until
he grabbed my hand well until you went
down to touching the stuff right so shut
down yeah and you're you can't do that
you can't do that so everything's good
you said your peace everything's okay
he's gone we moved him on okay I don't
like my truth said we don't necessarily
agree or disagree with what he's doing
he's just it is what it is we're here to
keep the peace and that's the whole
point of this thing right so you guys
get to give your Viewpoint and be out
here and show solidarity thing so
everyone's good all we can all head head
on home
[Applause]
safely